what makes a great comic premise a great
comic premise
in a way I I don't want to say it has to
be this because in reality if you have
an idea and you write it out and it
works that that premise was great for
you it's so it's not something that's
objective it's something that's
subjective it's something that
that creates
a desire in you to tell the entire story
I mean haven't you ever seen a blurb for
a movie and you said I wish I had
thought of that that's what you're
looking for you're looking for something
to
stir your own imagination so that the
the story is is kind of exploding in
your own imagination before you even can
get to the the the typewriter or the uh
the computer uh so uh so for me uh it's
very subjective I think what what
some things that are common to Great
comic objectives is the the the big lie
that there's some impossible or
improbable thing
that could never happen or could
probably never happen but since it does
happen
it affects this main character and these
other
um supporting characters and you wonder
well what will happen then
so so when you create a comic premise
um the the the better the premise is the
better it is a tool to excite your own
imagination to
to make you go oh my God I I gotta write
this down because it's it's it's already
occurring to you in your in your in your
own imagination your in your own head
um there are a couple of things that you
want to think about as you develop it
you want to tell one line one lie only
so so in other words
um let's say your
uh comic premise is that there's this uh
there's this anthropomorphic duck
right or chicken there's this
anthropomorphic chicken this little
chicken and the chicken thinks that the
sky is falling and he made a big deal
about it and it turned out the sky
wasn't falling and so he's embarrassed
his father and he's embarrassed himself
and he's humiliated himself at a time of
life in which chickens don't want to
humiliate themselves middle school now
that's the premise of Chicken Little the
Disney movie
in the middle of Chicken Little there's
an alien invasion
okay
I would say
that maybe you don't need the Alien
Invasion that maybe you need if you
didn't think your story of in a
humiliated chicken trying to you know
dig out from under the humiliation in
middle school was enough of a story then
you wanted to come up with a different
premise you wanted to create something
differently
um so that it would Propel you to the
end of the story if you're throwing in
an alien invasion you're telling me
you're all right away well this idea
wasn't good enough it wasn't strong
enough to to sustain
um
the Pixar movie Inside Out
Pixar movie Inside Out had a great
premise the premise is is that all these
different aspects of our personality
they all have they're all live in our
brains and uh what happens is is that
two of them somehow get shunted off to
uh to another another region and the
little girl whose brain it is starts
going amok and they gotta get back
wow that's a that's a great premise now
could that ever happen I don't know are
there little people in our brains
telling us what to do it's an
interesting idea so what would happen
then now the premise
is only the start
because
you have to you have to people you have
to develop the premise through character
and theme
because ultimately even though it's a
movie about a guy who wakes up it's the
same day every day or a guy or a guy who
kid who wishes he was big and he wakes
up and he's a 30 year old man or a bunch
of uh uh personalized entities in some
little girl's brain
what is it about
and when when somebody asks you what
it's about they're not asking you what's
the premise they're asking you what's
the meaning why am I spending two hours
watching this and who are the characters
that are happening to because you have
to develop
the premise for through character as
opposed to well now I'm going to make
the characters do this now I'm going to
make the characters do do that what
would the characters do given this
premise Guided by the theme
so Inside Out is is a great story
because
I think for two years and again somebody
in the internet will correct me on that
uh I think for two years
they the if you know inside out
um Amy polar played Joy and uh I forget
the name of the actress I think
something Smith
Lois Smith maybe played sadness and as
you know low joy and sadness go on a
trip but for the first two years it was
joy and fear Amy Poehler and Bill Hader
and the movie didn't work
the movie didn't work because no matter
what they did they had funny stuff
happen but it just was not not
coalescing
because when they went back and I think
they had child psychologists and nerds
neuro neuroscientists come to talk to
them they realized that the opposite of
joy is in fear
the opposite of joy is sadness and you
can't have joy
without sadness
which is the theme that you have to be
to be a fully actualized person you need
all parts of yourself you can't just
dismiss one part
and it didn't work with fear so when
they finally got the idea
we have to we've got the wrong
characters on this journey
then the movie then the movie kind of
found its way and and and and took off
so a comic premise is some impossible
you know in in in the comic heroes
journey book I call it WTF what the [ __ ]
something something happens that that is
either impossible a guy wakes up the
same day over and over again that's
impossible or improbable
um
a a woman decides to go to uh her Best
Friend's Wedding in order to uh destroy
it
you know mostly you're you're you know
if you if somebody's got if some guy's
getting married and you think well I
should have married him maybe just stay
home and drink that weekend
um so impossible or improbable and then
who are the characters that are called
on characters are called on either
through need or theme
you need a character
in Groundhog Day you need a cameraman
because how is he going to do a remote
if nobody's holding the camera
but then you also have
characters brought on through theme
ultimately Groundhog Day is about
how can you be a good person in the
world
and so you needed the world and so they
they said it uh because Groundhog Day
happens in a small town that small town
becomes the world and those are the old
other than the station manager in the
very beginning of the picture that we
never see again
the only other characters are his
producer
the the the love interest you know the
magical object desire
uh and everybody else in the town
uh because you know who's not in
Groundhog Day the president of the
United States because it has nothing to
do with politics his mother because it
doesn't really have anything to do with
family or Stephanie
if you Google Groundhog Day what will
come up in the in the uh in Google
very very top of the list is the second
draft done by Harold Ramis and Danny
Rubin and in that second draft there's
this character called Stephanie which is
which was a response to a executive uh
note saying how does this happen I don't
believe I I don't know how it happens
you got to put the audience will be
confused the audience will be confused
you have to put something in there that
explains to them how it happens so
Harold Ramis put in against his better
judgment he put in
um
the character of Stephanie who's into
Ouija boards and crystals and and she
was dumped by Bill Murray's character
and so she puts a curse on him
so think about it groundhog if you know
Groundhog Day if you don't know
Groundhog Day go watch it it's really a
wonderful film even though it's many
many years old
um
character Stephanie well if she puts a
curse on him then don't you have to go
back and get her to take the curse off
and
and then doesn't that diminish the theme
to be as opposed to how can you be a
good person in the world to be how could
you be a good boyfriend kind of
diminishes it so when the people who ran
the studio were all fired and a new
executive came in uh the guy said why do
you need this character Stephanie for
a recorded instance of a good executive
note and so they took it out because
they never wanted in the first place
could Groundhog Day worked if Rita had
been the Arrogant selfish one
and the Bill Murray character Phil was
it yeah had been this kind sort of
gentle man
could have still have been funny
what if we switched what if we took the
the two characters and switched their
roles
well but who's who's waking up the same
day over and over again that's a good
point okay what do you see if it if it's
if it's still him then why are we
torturing this nice guy okay what if it
was Rita
well then that would that would work if
she was somebody who needed to go on the
journey you don't want to pull Wings off
of flies you don't want to torture
characters who don't need transformation
don't need torturing
characters who go through trauma need to
go through the trauma thank God for the
trauma
because the trauma helps them transform
so if they don't need the trauma then
you're just
you're just torturing somebody
for really no good not a great reason